you
I love Fisher random okay let's think
here these guys don't need to move
they're already developed just move
these guys and we're good to go he's
gonna give me trouble I don't want to go
here unless maybe I have first moved
this pond how do i get my queen out good
grief good grief who could argue with
that the rooks right there backing him
up and he could go here where he's not
obstructing any ponds hmm let's get my
night developed and you know what I'm
gonna do with my queen she's gonna run
out of here this pond is gonna try to
grab some space and my Queens gonna come
up here might be important too because
if the night plays here I don't want the
night to jump into this square that
could be quite annoying what a weird
position huh you sometimes you could
envision Oh after a few moves it's going
to be like an English opening or take on
this particular structure but not in
this case this guy well just both nights
neither neither one of them could get to
the or natural like squares well he
needs to play I don't want to go to
squares kind of locked in there if I go
too then I've created some weaknesses
that I are irreparable it definitely
don't want a week and see for this night
would be licking his chaps jump right in
there or just a single step I should
probably address my queen position
should i do this right away should
develop there's a lot of [ __ ] ups a lot
of should i do this should i do that
just make up your mind and move who
cares what about this is there any
sneakiness over here on this diagonal
she's not gonna bother me let's see for
okay candidate moves our c4 and I should
maybe look at this first since it
challenges something on blacks
I to the board let's look at the more
aggressive bows first this is certainly
more aggressive and also will help out
this bishop but maybe it's just short
lived after c4 takes takes yes you could
see here but I'm gonna slam the door
soon with this boom boom boom night here
how do I defend my pond yeah do I have a
good answer to that one no I don't
taking a lot of time here but it's
already very tricky let's look at this
one more time push if takes I go here if
night here I could go here I just it's
so difficult to defend that pawn on c4
all right let's develop let's develop
maybe maybe black is gonna do this yeah
it's very awkward I mean the night right
here obstructs this pond so I don't have
to worry about this clearly but this I
do mmm what's my queen doing somebody
tell me nothing let's get rolling oh my
goodness i just dropped upon no i didn't
okay i think i have to make my [ __ ] up
look super ugly let's go here if um the
night was gonna take here i can always
attack the pinned piece but i really
didn't look at that first I should have
because the night maybe could have moved
and he oh actually he would be able to
and then the Queen could get this bish
up so that move was available but now
let's just reinforce that pond oh boy my
night on g3 is stupid ah
how am I gonna castle should I castle
are either of us gonna castle I guess I
go here I'm not sure why because I don't
need to even move him if I want to
Castle Queen sided I could Castle Queen
side but my rook would stay where he is
and it's just like that would end up
happening I could Castle kingside I
could have done that as soon as I moved
my night here so there baby step in
their bishops I'm gonna do the same
little copycat trick little copycat
technique and I watch out for those pawn
push I'm never taking I want to keep
control over this square if i take I'm I
lose control I'll let the tension sit if
pond here I go here you might want to go
here anyhow my queen wants to go here
I'm not sure where my king belongs and
I'm going to keep that option open I
believe that's one of the most important
features of Fisher and I'm not showing
your cards with your Kings location
maybe he stays where he is from the
current arrangement maybe goes Kings
side or queenside keep those options
open I'm not sure which one is better
maybe Flacco's queenside I'm more
inclined to go in this direction whereas
otherwise maybe not so much since I've
moved a lot of pawns on this sector of
the board so Queen h3h five come to mind
for me I'm not going to be so quick to
Castle kingside what else my black deal
is blacking to throw a night in my
position this night I think I have him
under control is this Bishop going to
try and take out my night and then
create an accident on this square I
think I'm gonna go with this why not if
you're gonna take like this you've
weakened f5 you've also made this pond
more accessible pawn push whoa whoa whoa
whoa this King is crazy why is he going
there did was that Mouse slip that must
have been a mouse lip maybe not is this
King trying to get here because you
could have castle in one move and the
King would I got there he's trying to
provoke me
me night here come get me as he saying
he's trying to lure me into a central
post 95 it's got here that can't be too
comfortable can it you're in a pen gotta
run here run for your life I could do
this let's throw a night in there can't
do this the night I'll take him right
out this is pretty common I don't see
that you can kick my queen off of this
dog and also last night could still jump
in here yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna get my
king in that same position one move most
likely i don't think it's a good idea to
throw my king to go kingside castle
maybe maybe then black is going to take
like this so now this is actually losing
move right can't take like this I'll
take him out I think I could have taken
with the minor piece as well right this
is very difficult because this nights in
a pin I'm ready to take here and take
the night castle queenside everything is
very well coordinated rook to h1 pile up
on this pond now this is I'm on the rook
and the night so I don't take the night
because the Queen captures and defends
so is there any trick any trick and you
trick with Queen takes Knight I don't
believe it let's just take it hang on no
no I could sneak away for a brief second
I was wondering if my queen is going to
be trapped after this capture if you do
it immediately I take on this square
take like this and if Bishop here I get
to go here Queen side castle who cares
about this actually I care about it
night here Bishop takes here with check
why would you do that why would you
allow that let me just get castled oh
that's how your castle I forgot it's
been that long it's been that long
forgot out a castle if Bishop takes I'm
going to take here and then play King to
be one oh my I'm not trapped it's run
away okay with these trades or even on
time but I'm up a piece sneak attack
Bishop here oh my goodness look at all
the pieces that are on this diagonal
it's defended now let's take here before
the door is closed pawn push I don't
want to allow that huh let's get rid of
this rook I want to be able to post up
here with check less than 30 for both
bishops on adjacent diagonals that is a
pin attack that pinned piece not that it
really matter she's gonna go here anyhow
I should have went hunting down this
pond okay good game let's go back got um
interesting let's see this position
right here yeah i think this ec i was
reluctant deploy my night to this square
because it obstructs this pond but it's
interesting deployment of this night hmm
you see I was more
I didn't mind obstructing my Jeep on oh
oh you have this move right here right
now you could be capturing actually the
very first moment right here soon i do
this move i think you could take this
because my bishops unprotected so if i
do this and push you could move your
night here and give check and then take
my bishop think that was a missed
opportunity as a follow-up maybe you're
able after here maybe if your night
wants support one move later you then
have a five think this was a missed
opportunity Knight takes pawn III you
don't take on c2 with check because I
take and my rook is defending my bishop
but takes III Knight f3 I take your
night your Queens is right down into my
territory recapturing a piece yeah that
was missed and maybe even here still
instead of the night little I think take
stakes in here although yeah I think you
can still do that because you are
winning material so I think we both are
missing a couple opportunities for this
to actually be good tactically maybe
interesting arrangement um yeah I don't
know just castle right maybe he was
forgetting just like I was forgetting to
see moving my king to see one but could
save yourself a move he knows that but
uh I think I think maybe we were both
forgetting for a little bit all right I
think it's really downhill at this point
there this is this is definitely a
losing move because if I break down the
position the nights in a pin so what
this is maybe the the last point in the
game really what can you be doing
different well the earliest point was
that capture i'm pretty sure maybe maybe
another thing was to not even allow me
to have this advance maybe as soon as
i'm doing h4 you could be playing age
I've that might be another one to
consider at least yeah it's tricky now
because I get to he really doesn't have
a choice whereas my pond does it's one
way to look at it right you really don't
want to take you just very weakening
taking away from the center subjecting
your pond well he's now very weak on h7
if you do g 5 f-5 is weak i could do
this he's maybe a target my pond is very
deep in your position I have the choices
I could take I could push and I keep you
guessing I keep this tension very common
thing to do not just in 960 just in
general to keep the tension keep your
opponent guessing if your pond has more
choices than your opponent spawn keep
the tension okay this I got broken down
quickly after that each six move but ok
let me close out good game make an X
you